well another issue the school district
is grappling with is vaccines arc omana
is live at the board meeting with what
teachers are saying about that tonight
orco
denise's school board meeting is
happening right now just beyond these
doors here it's been going on for about
an hour now the main focus at tonight's
meeting is on the health care issues for
teachers but the topic of a potential
vaccine mandate for ccsd employees is
still top of mind for many
based on the board's decision ccsc
superintendent dr jesus jarrah has the
power to require the covet vaccine for
all school district employees it's been
a heated topic of debate in recent
school board meetings when it comes to
the shot many say each teacher should
decide whether or not to get it i just
feel it's a person's choice especially
something that's not been around that
long i know i felt comfortable taking it
but i shouldn't speak for other people
that's not fair at last check the
mandate is still being negotiated
between superintendent jara and employee
bargaining groups such as the teachers
union
for now the district is requiring
unvaccinated employees to get tested for
covid every week we'll have more on the
board meeting tonight at 11. for now
reporting live in las vegas orco mana
live local now